wir haben Bilder gesehen aus der
Silvesternacht wir haben aber danach
brutale prügelvideos hermalig gesehen
der Sozialarbeiter in Offenbach
unterwegs ist auch aus Rastatt
beispielsweise aus Karlsruhe Mädchen
dort
überraschenderweise muss man sagen
Mädchen die brutal zugeschlagen haben
noch auf ihre Opfer getreten haben hier
sehen wir dieses sehen als die bereits
am Boden lagen und das erschreckende
diese Szenen dann auch ja zum Angeben
stolz ins Netz gestellt haben er Malik
erklären Sie mir das ich kenne das ganz
ehrlich überhaupt nicht aus meiner
Jugend solche
brutalsten Szenen was muss in dem Moment
in den Köpfen derer Vorgehen die immer
noch mal und noch mal zutreten erstmal
glaube ich dass wir in unserer
Gesellschaft momentan ein echtes Gewalt
Problem haben das hängt er nicht mit
etien oder irgendwelche Herkunft wir
haben ein echtes Gewalt Problem ist das
sehe ich auch
und und ich sehe auch dass es Gruppen
gibt da ist die Hemmschwelle gerade
jetzt mit den neuen Netzwerken wann ist
cool und so die ist nach unten gegangen
mein Ansatz ist ist dann eher dass man
nicht über die Leute redet sondern mit
den Leuten redet was ist mit dir
passiert dass du überhaupt sowas
unmenschliches machst da muss doch
irgendwie eine Hemmschwelle überbrochen
sein Kommen Sie dafür antworten wenn Sie
beispielsweise bei solchen täteren
nachfragen wie konnte das ich hatte bis
jetzt mit solchen Täterinnen und Täter
immer einen ganzen Berufsleben doch nie
zu tun gehabt mit dieser Brutalität das
hatte ich noch nicht es gab früher jetzt
auch in meiner Jugend da gab es immer da
gab es die blaue Jacken die schwarze ja
da gab diese ganggeschichte und so das
war eine Jugendszene schon immer Thema
aber diese Brutalität habe ich jetzt
selber im Jugendzentrum oder so oder
jetzt in oder jetzt immer ein Umfeld in
Offenbach habe ich so exzessiv noch nie
ich habe viel davon gehört ich habe doch
den ein oder anderen mal mitbekommen und
das war das und das war da waren junger
Mann der hat nämlich ein Problem gehabt
und er hat bei uns im Boxclub
Arbeitsauflagen gemacht und jetzt war
das Gute weil der hat bei uns eine ganz
klare Ansage gekriegt der so und und war
auch dann bei uns im Training weil bei
uns läuft es so wer bei uns ins Training
kommt da wollen wir die Zeugnisse sehen
wer in irgendein einfach schlechter ist
wie viel der muss in die Nachhilfe und
bei ihm war das Schulversagen und das
war das einzige wo er kommunizieren und
dann in der Gruppe cool sein wollte und
und nun war genau das Ding und dann hat
der junge Mann auch gesagt die haben von
mir Respekt und dann habe ich gesagt die
haben vor dir Angst Respekt ist was ganz
anderes warum hast du von mir Respekt
ich kann dir kam auf dem Bauchnabel
gucken wegen mein Bester trifft und dann
sagt der junge Mann ja weil du hilfst
und du machst gut
und da muss man mit den Leuten reden und
es tut auch manchmal weh und da gibt's
auch manchmal Niederlagen die man in
unserem Beruf aushalten muss aber aber
ich finde es ganz wichtig dass man genau
diese Themen es gibt ja viele Projekte
die die Jugendlichen da ist mittlerweile
abholen so und es ist und und ich habe
manchmal das Gefühl dass die
das ist da gibt es einfach Leute das ist
einfach für die wie Kino das Wetter
wenn wir dieses Szenen sehen hier Intro
sie sind vielleicht an der Polizeiarbeit
noch einen Tick mehr dran sie kennen
solche oder ähnliche Szenen aus Berlin
was muss in den Momenten in den Köpfen
derer Vorgehen die eben noch mal und
noch mal zutreten
wurde diejenigen Fragen die das machen
ich meine wer Menschen die am Boden
liegen gegen Kopf tritt nimmt nicht nur
schwer zu Verletzungen sondern auch den
Tod einer Personen kaufen von früher
nicht habe ich gerade sagen mein Freund
wurde von einem Nazi genau vor mir genau
auf diese Art und Weise verprügelt in
meiner Jugend möchte eine Sache sagen
dass er der Ciao korrekterweise auch
vorhin richtig angesprochen und auch
einmalig gerade
wir haben durchaus schon Werte Verlust
da gegen das Jahr nicht mehr mit
Menschen reden ja dass wir auch Respekt
vor Menschen nicht mehr haben weil wir
ihn gar nicht mehr begegnen wir ziehen
uns in Social Media zurück das sind
heutige Gegebenheiten diese Bilder
hätten sie auch vor 20 25 Jahren
bekommen wenn es die Möglichkeit gegeben
hätte also wir müssen auch ehrlich sein
wir haben heute viel mehr Bilder davon
aber das nicht die Frage die wir uns
hier stellen müssen sondern die Frage
ist und deswegen bin ich hier warum ist
die Gewalt gegen Einsatzkräfte in den
letzten Jahren hoch wir haben auch an
Silvester nicht darüber gesprochen dass
auch Menschen von Raketen verletzt
wurden die nicht der Polizei oder
Feuerwehr ne aber wir müssen darüber
reden und Frau hat hier in
Regierungsverantwortung in Berlin ist ja
DIE LINKE es wurde eine Studienauftrag
gegeben die sich auch die Berliner
Polizei angucken sollte das kann jetzt
als Misstrauen sehen ich achtet relativ
sachlich gesehen schauen wir uns noch
mal an da wird nämlich rauskommen dass
wir eine sehr bürgerfreundliche Berliner
Polizei haben dass die sehr viel Macht
und wir haben auch viel über
Hilfsorganisationen gesprochen nicht
staatlich Organisation
interessanterweise diejenigen die
Menschen beraten sollen die ohnehin
Problem mit dem Rechtsstaat haben die
sich nicht aufgenommen fühlen die wissen
manchmal gar nicht was sind eigentlich
staatlich Auftrag der Polizei das ist
nämlich in ihrer Studie darauf gekommen
und das sollte uns zu denken geben dass
wir gar nicht mehr wissen was müssen
eigentlich recht staatliche
rechtsstaatliche Aufgaben sein was muss
die Polizei eigentlich tun wir reden
immer über Polizei Gewalt ja Polizei ist
die einzige Organisation die Gewalt
gesetzmäßig anwenden darf natürlich
nicht rechtswidrig aber jeder nach einer
Demo hier Friedrich sein Kreuzberg sagt
hier polizeigewaltig schlagen auf einen
keiner weiß was sie eigentlich machen
müssen und jetzt sind wir kurz bei dem
Fall mit der syrischen Familie den sie
ansprechen der Kollege hat vollkommen
falsche Kommunikation gewesen möchte ich
überhaupt nicht schön reden ja aber
Moment muss ich noch mal ganz kurz
erklären
zeigt einen Ausschnitt eines Einsatzes
der Berliner Polizei genau in einer
Wohnung die Kollegen waren da
die Kollegen waren da oben im Haftbefehl
zu vollstrecken ja weil ein
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe nicht bezahlt
wurde und das passiert dann hat sich da
ordentlich im Ton vergriffen
wurde ich voll unterschreiben aber und
jetzt sind wir bei einem wichtigen Punkt
was macht denn dann eine Partei in
Regierungsverantwortung in Berlin sie
veranstaltet eine Pressekonferenz und
lässt die Familie einfach Ihre Sicht von
sich geben das schauen sich dann nämlich
auch ganz viele syrische Familien an es
ist ein rechtsstaatliches vorgehen dass
genau geguckt wird hat der Kollege
richtig gehandelt ja nein das
disziplinarrechtliche Maßnahmen
eingeleitet werden ja nein aber was
senden sie denn für ein Signal sie geben
eine Moment und wir sind bei den
Hilfsorganisationen und die Studie hat
es deutlich gesagt sehr sehr klein aber
eine Sache noch bitte Ordnung nein aber
wenn sie sprechen dass die Berliner
Polizei zumindest in Teilen ganz
offenbar ja sich von der Politik hier in
Berlin vernachlässigt fühlt können sie
es verstehen nein das wurde uns auch so
nicht mitgeteilt ehrlich gesagt wir sind
ja regelmäßig im Austausch also dass wir
wie gesagt schon relativ lange relativ
gut zu und ich höre auch das was viele
Beamte auf der Straße sagen und die vor
allen Dingen die sich dort in der
Silvesternacht ja die brutal angegriffen
wurden die fühlen sich nicht gestützt
von ihnen durch was denn also es gibt
Gesetze die sie schützen es gibt wir
haben sehr viel gekümmert um bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen das haben wir auch
zum Teil erreicht wir haben uns darum
gekümmert dass mehr Menschen mit
Migrationsgeschichte in die Polizei
gehen und so weiter also es wurde sehr
viel gemacht aber ob jetzt bodycams der
richtige weg sind oder nicht da gibt es
eben Diskussionen das muss man
wissenschaftlich evaluieren das machen
wir uns auch aber es gibt natürlich
viele Sachen sich die Polizei wünscht
alles sofort unterschreiben sondern es
muss kritisch überprüft werden dieses
Video wie gesagt es zeigte nur ein
Ausschnitt dieses Einsatz und sie und
sie laden anschließend die syrische
Familie vor und lassen die erzählen und
der Polizist durfte sein Sachverhalt
aber nicht erklären ist das die Sache
wie sie Gewichten jeder darf seine
Sachverhalt erklären wenn er das möchte
es ging uns als Linke darum dass diese
Menschen auch mal gehört werden weil der
Zugang den Menschen die die Sprache
nicht gut sprechen die vielleicht erst
hier sind wissen sie hat mit dieser
Familie gesprochen dieses Tochter die
dabei war die schwer traumatisiert warum
hat diese Familie kein Recht ihre
Perspektive auszutreten sie haben
ermöglicht dass sie das auch mal sagen
kann weil überall wird nur über sie
gesprochen über die Polizeibeamten
gesprochen warum kann diese Familie
nicht auch sozusagen gehört werden ich
finde das gehört dazu und das ist ihr
gutes Recht übrigens da war ich gerade
letzte Woche beim Prozess äh hat das
auch gemacht die ist nämlich verprügelt
worden auch gleiche Szene leider auch
Frauen ja die auf sie eingeschlagen sind
rechtsradikales Milieu oder irgendwie
rechts offenes Milieu und die die
Landwirte hat vom Krankenhaus noch mit
Instagram gefilmt und ihre Perspektive
in die Welt gebracht das hat überhaupt
erst in Gang gebracht dass es dieses
Verfahren gab anzeigen und so weiter und
dass ich darum gestellt wird
und das ist doch wichtig
weil wir wir sehen brutale Angriffe in
der silvestern
den ersten Tagen danach die Berliner
Polizei hat das gemacht auch bestimmte
Tätergruppen und dann drei Wochen später
sitzen wir hier vertreten auch durch die
Berliner Politik und sprechen über eine
syrische Familie die verbale
Polizeigewalt erlebt hat wir sprechen
überforderngriffe ist natürlich gibt von
Rechtsradikalen verläuft diese Debatte
Stück weit sinnbildlich für ähnliche
Debatten in den vergangenen Jahren immer
wieder die die Politik geführt hat
nee wir reden ja über alle möglichen
Formen von Gewalt auch von reichsbürgern
von Rechtsextremisten wir reden über
Kriminalität von politischen Aktivisten
die beispielsweise in Lutzerath gesetzt
brechen und auch Polizisten angreifen
also Gewalt gibt es natürlich in
unterschiedlichen Formen und
unterschiedlichen Ausprägungen aber
eines scheint mir schon wichtig ich
kenne jetzt den konkreten Fall in Berlin
nicht wir haben das in lützerath auch
erlebt und wir erleben das in solchen
Fällen auch immer als ob hier von zwei
gleichberecht auszugehen wäre wir haben
auf der einen Seite eine Polizei die
Recht und Gesetz durchsetzt die auch
unmittelbaren Zwang anwenden darf um
Recht und Gesetz durchzusetzen wenn dem
anderweitig nicht Genüge getan wird und
wir haben auf der anderen Seite
Rechtsbrecher und insofern ist
vollkommen klar da braucht es kein
Austausch von Argumenten sondern wenn es
eine richterliche Entscheidung gibt oder
wenn die Gesetzeslage klar ist dann ist
dem nachzukommen und wenn das nicht
passiert dann macht es die Polizei mit
unmittelbarem Zwang von allen Seiten
denn das gehört natürlich tatsächlich zu
dem vollständigen Bild nutzerat haben
sie gerade angesprochen und diese Szenen
die sich dort abspielten die haben sich
in Teilen überhaupt nicht unterschieden
von dem was in der Silvesternacht
passiert auch Angriffe mit Pyrotechnik
mit Molotow Cocktails auf ihre
beamtenheriento also
wo bleibt da der Unterschied also
erstmal möchte ich mal ganz kurz was
sagen das hat der frei schon gut
angesprochen auch da weil ich eben
meinte man gibt Einzelnen die
Möglichkeit sehr sehr viel rauszutragen
ich habe auch bei lützerath
klimaaktivisten kann man sie ja nennen
aber letztlich wenn man Steine schmeißt
auf Menschen ist man strafzetader ja die
sagen oh ich finde das Polizei Aufgebot
hier völlig unverhältnismäßig und die
Polizei macht sich zum würde von RWE das
ist eine politische Entscheidung die
oberinstanzlich juristisch aus sollte
also ausdiskutiert ist da gibt's keinen
für und wieder mehr das ist jetzt nicht
wie im Hambacher Forst vor ein paar
Jahren ja sondern es ist klar was mit
diesem Gelände passiert und die Polizei
hatte im Rahmen der Amtshilfe dort für
Sicherheit zusammen und wenn ich sehe
das schon vor der Räumungen lützerat
Steine Flaschen auf ein
Kommunikationsteam der Polizei
geschmissen werden das sind Leute die
haben keine Westen an ja die sind nur
mit so einer gelben Jacke erkennbar als
Kommunikation die werden eingepflanzt
mit Steinen also worüber reden wir jetzt
hier eigentlich und dann muss man schon
auch sagen und das meine ich natürlich
soll man allen Menschen eine Stimme
geben ja aber so eine Pressekonferenz
wäre doch schön gewesen wenn sie auch
jemand die Polizei eingeladen hätte und
wenn es die Polizeipräsidentin gewesen
wäre dass der Kollege nichts sagt ist
doch klar hallo der hat einen
Rechtsverfahren wir hatten disziplinar
fahren
überall dazu diese Familie
Präsidentin von Berlin wer will in
diesen Zeiten eigentlich Polizist oder
Polizisten werden würden sie sich das
antun hat also mein Berufswunsch war
seit ich zehn Jahre alt bin
Menschenrechtsanwältin zu werden und
jetzt habe ich etwas ähnliches gemacht
deswegen wäre das mein Berufswunsch
nicht gewesen nein nach Neukölln einem
Freitagabend Samstagabend mit einem
Streifenwagen reinzufahren und dort für
Ordnung sorgen müssen
wie gesagt also Polizei ist nicht mein
Berufswunsch das müssen Sie mir jetzt
verzeihen dass ich das nicht machen
möchte das liegt aber nicht daran dass
Neukölln besonders schlimmer Ort ist
wenn sie mal die ich möchte eine Sache
dazu sagen heute ist ein Aktionstag
gegen Gewalt der Sonnenallee und das
machen die migrantisierten Gastronomen
die sagen wir wollten sogar dass die da
kostenlos Essen das war dann rechtlich
nicht möglich also die Menschen die dort
leben die all die Menschen mit Migration
selber Zweifel ob es Neukölln ganz weit
nach vorne bringen würde aber noch
einmal bleiben bei der Frage also
entschieden ich ich finde das Wort toll
ich finde das anders war toll bitte was
ja wo ist denn was ist denn man Neukölln
so problematisch ist ein vielfältiger
Bezirk es gibt überall Probleme aber
bestimmt nicht nur in Neukölln wenn
jetzt die ganze Republik auf Neuköln
falsch ja gesprochen es gibt ganz viele
Orte Probleme ich wollte von ihnen ja
nur wissen ob sie sich das antun würden
und zur Polizei gehen würden sie haben
dann den Abzweig genommen dass sie
sowieso schon immer eine Berufswunsch
hätten wie wäre das mit ihren Kindern
wenn die den Berufswunsch äußern wenn
sie sagen macht es oder würden Sie
beraten also ich finde dass meine Kinder
eine selbstbestimmte Entscheidung
treffen und wenn sie das möchten ich
würde ihnen nicht abraten weil Neukölln
ein besonders gefährliches Pflaster ist
darauf wollen sie ja hinaus dass sicher
nicht sondern ich würde sagen mit
welchen Risiken und Konsequenzen dieser
Beruf sowie auch andere Berufe
einhergehen also auch Politikerin sein
das nicht ohne Risiko wir kriegen auch
mordnachrichten wegen alle möglichen
Sachen es gibt viele Berufsrisiken
Polizei hat auch viele Berufsrisiken das
würde ich natürlich offen auf den Tisch
liegen aber nicht wegen Neukölln wenn er
sagen würde ich will explizit nach
Neukölln da hätte ich jetzt keine
Einwände ehrlich gesagt ob er in
Grunewald oder noch neu Köln möchte